if you can perform on bad days I think
that's what it takes to build something
over time the only way to avoid
criticism is to say nothing is to do
nothing is to be nothing where you
really have a superpower is if
comparison is challenging you to be
better just know that you aspiring to
start a YouTube channel or you aspiring
to build an online business is going to
induce more pressure I want a name of
somebody that you are jealous of on
YouTube Mel here from the think media
team I'm excited to get into interview
with Sean canel and we are going to get
into some juicy questions today because
um we've got some good ones in here Sean
I'm excited to do this interview with
you because I think I have a unique
perspective from knowing you for the
last really what's just five years as we
know in small business it's like dog
years it feels like it's like 20 years I
feel like we've been through a lot so um
let's just get right into it I'm fired
up all right um first question people
often see the success but not the
struggle m can you share a moment in
your early YouTube days where you
thought this just isn't for me man
there's been a lot of struggles over the
years I mean I started YouTube in 2007
for my local church started personally
posting kind of on the side in
2010 and started to just post on
multiple channels had a channel called
think International had a channel had a
business Channel Clear Vision media had
my Sean canel Channel and there was many
times many uploads where I would maybe
feel what you'd call a bright spot I'd
get like 5,000 views I'd get 3,300 views
which is pretty significant but then I
would look eventually I got monetized
and I realize YouTube paid me
$346 for those views and I just my heart
sunk because I felt like the gap between
the goal of going full-time and where I
was was so far so many times over the
years where I would feel like this
incremental progress I feel like times
on YouTube you feel like you make five
steps forward and then you take like six
steps back in terms of going through
slumps and Seasons but really I was just
committed to the Long Haul of YouTube
and to be honest some of the slow growth
was because I was just doing it as a
side hustle like I had a full-time job
was focusing on family and other things
and just doing YouTube when I could so
even though these setbacks I wish the
growth was faster even though I wish the
growth happened more rapidly I was just
committed to it Max cow like I'm just
going to keep uploading videos as long
as it takes as my side thing why I'm
doing my main thing it' be clear that
was 2010 to about 2016 2015 was kind of
the transition year so that's about five
years of just chipping away at the side
hustle and I hoped I would have got
viral and been like rescued but it
wasn't until I got like focused
disciplined and really went all in that
things began to speed up so I was just
chipping away at things on the side so
with the that story of you saying that
you really did have that mindset of just
being persistent throughout maybe there
wasn't a moment when you thought you
actually would quit but what were some
of the most difficult moments in that
Journey when it really tested you for me
the difficult moments were actually life
moments more than YouTube moments and so
certainly in 2007 I started posting for
the church in 2009 I started my channel
called Clear Vision media which was just
a portfolio of videos for my video
production business wasn't really a
channel I still hoped it was growing I
thought it was a channel but it wasn't
really a channel that was value based it
was just a portfolio and that was a year
that my wife Sony almost died and that
the housing crisis was happening and we
were losing our home and
so those external circumstances applied
so much pressure that it did make it
incredibly difficult to work on my side
hustle or to work on anything sometimes
you just want to shut down Retreat and
so fast forward whether it was drama at
work drama and marriage a hard Seasons
there was Seasons where I think every
relationship has challenges and may be
fights we've been through Cycles where
we'd get into counseling and marriage
counseling which I'm a huge fan of and I
think it's a very powerful thing that
shouldn't be taboo you know I think
counseling is something that is um has
been incredibly helpful to us and
so some of the most challenging times
would be I would schedule a live stream
at 10:00
a.m. and I would fight all morning with
Sonia and then still need and still have
that live stream some of the most
challenging moments would be being up
late with marriage conflict processing
an issue and then having a big shoot day
the next morning and then similarly
would be conflict that could happen
relationally once we got into the think
media season building the business
there's just a lot of pressure and I
think the the takeaway principle is
trying to learn how
to let business be business and to show
up and deliver regardless of your
emotions we have to be a little bit
careful of that because if you're just
bearing your emotions and never
processing them but there's just
something about whether you feel like it
or not turning on the camera and
shooting the video there's something
about knowing how to alter your state in
a healthy way knowing that all right I
need to go on a walk get some fresh air
let my anger cool down pray about it
fire off a text apologize resolve the
issue as much as possible for this
moment and then get on camera and
deliver and then I think the other
biggest one though would be the The
Chronic pain piece at at 32 I'm about to
turn 40 I really started to notice I had
a some pretty extreme pain in my wrists
fingers forearms
that is essentially RSI repetitive
strain injury repetitive stress injury
very common for computer programmers and
Gamers and I've been editing video so
intensely from 20 to 32 that without
good organomics or good weight training
or strength training that um I developed
this consistent pain and it's been
something I've still been wrestling with
it thank God that today things are
better and I'm improving
but due to the nature of that exact time
interestingly enough being the
transition time into entrepreneurship
being a solopreneur at first doing
YouTube full-time now building think
media which is about seven years old
that like the entire time of building
think media building YouTube has been
chronic pain like the whole time so it's
kind of been this tension to manage and
I I don't on the one hand I think like
maybe I'm not a great example because I
don't know what I would have done but
like I do know that some people who do
find kind of a carpal tunnel RSI thing
they will take like L and I and be off
work for 6 months or 12 months or be
unemployed and be rehabbing in some way
I've never done that and it's maybe
speaks to my personality whereas maybe
feeling the pressure on my shoulders to
provide for my family fight build the
company there's also though and I
admittedly today I have no excuse
because there is some margin there's an
incredible team and there's money in the
bank and as a result I also am like
doing physical therapy and so but I've
always been like working processing that
I never went to the extreme of just
checking out and and working on only
that but I've just continued to build
and the result is that there's been good
days and bad days but there's been times
where I will work on my computer as much
as I can for the hours in the morning
and that by two in the
afternoon uh at our Seattle place I
would get into bed rub my arms slather
them up with CBD Menthol on my elbows
both forearms and
hands um take Advil or Tylenol and sit
there and just think about the pain
being at level seven eight or nine and
being wondering like man is this is this
going to keep getting worse am I doing
damage as I continue to work with the
this and I've studied this extensively
so without going too deep into the whole
thing no doubt about it trying to build
something with chronic pain it's a lot
easier without trying to build something
with not feeling your best um but I
think the drive the mission the my
personality the my parents work ethic of
like kind of just suck it up GR and
Barett my wife who's incredibly
inspiring who's
also co-founder of the company and deals
with different chronic pain throughout
the years and I think it's a very
sensitive subject cuz I would never want
to encourage somebody to push themselves
too hard but I look back really with no
regrets other than I would wish I would
have worked out in my 30s and exercised
more and done preventative measures to
maintain my posture and muscles and
health and the rounded shoulders and
neck and strength training and all that
kind of stuff but fast forward to today
you know it kind of is what it is so
I've gone long on that question but I
think that the one of the hardest things
about being consistent with your online
business and your side hustle is that
life's going to happen family members
get sick drama Comes Your Way sickness
Comes Your Way health comes your way and
perhaps the difference of those who
break through and build something and
those who don't is
those that just essentially crumble
under under under the heavy pressure of
life I want to say that with empathy but
if if you can develop the mental
toughness and a fortitude to push
through when you want to quit if you can
perform on bad days I think that's what
it takes to build something over time
cuz you're there's no way you're ever
going to be only have a series of good
days with where it's when times you know
when the going gets tough the tough get
going I think success is really made in
those tough times and some of the things
I've learned absolutely and I think from
the perspective of somebody working with
you we didn't have any idea how much
pain you were going through or or all
the different struggles that you went
through during that time you were very
good at um segmenting those things off
and just showing up for work and showing
up your best even coming on camera we
wouldn't even know some days that you
were having like you're in pain you're
having a hard day so I do think that
there's something particular about your
personality that does set you apart but
as you look back I know you mentioned
one thing you would have liked to change
but for so many of our audience members
they come to us with these questions how
do I handle chronic pain how do I handle
spouses that don't support me kids
there's all these obstacles so you gave
a couple of uh recommendations for
people but what would you go back and
change other than just working out what
would you go back and change to help
people who are we in that situation now
yeah well let's come back to The
spouse's one I think let's isolate the
chronic pain one I think
that um I could have maybe worked a
little bit less but honestly I don't
think that that would have been the
change I think it would have been for
the level of output I wanted to do it
would be adding in strength training
that's what I would have changed in my
20s now that I'm working with some
physical therapists I'm working with uh
I'm blessed to be surrounded by our
students that are Health experts like a
benaz benadi or Justin from on it and
these different people who also have
YouTube channels so I'm so blessed that
I've got really high quality information
coming my way and I love what I do so
I'll actually do enjoy being in front of
a computer being at a desk or a standing
desk typing slack meetings live streams
hustling building the channel building
the business I enjoy that and what I've
been told is that if I want to be there
for let's call it an 8 hour day but it
could be four hours a day 6 hours a day
eight some days 10 12 you know whatever
it takes that I just need a commencent
amount of time in the gym and so it's
kind of like if you're going to be
pushing yourself and expecting high
performance out of your body out of your
mind then you need high performance
habits to support that in my 20s I've
always generally ate healthy but I'm
about to contradict that because I
remember every morning going to Bible
College I'd get the apple
pie from 711 where the list of
ingredients was like 700 things long
preservatives additives processed food
genetically modified organisms and I ate
that every day for breakfast and then I
remember I was drinking naked I don't
even know if they make it anymore I
think it went out of business it was
owned by Coke which was green juice with
58 gram of sugar and like not actually
green juice so fast forward to today I
was I was like steering towards Health
but now I won't even really touch like
Mighty greens which is pretty good from
suja but it's still like 38 grams I need
that Uber greens which is gnarly so so
it's like in my 20s I wasn't really
operating in high performance nutrition
I wasn't operating high performance and
oxygen exercise walking and I was I was
voling ing helping build a church which
I'm grateful for everything I invested
there I was fighting to wait tables in
the early days and support my family and
I was just was putting in a ton of work
the missing piece would have been making
time to just allow my muscles and
posture and stretching and yoga and
whatever so I think that's a big one and
I think that yes pulling back to create
enough margin for that however I could
have achieved that and now that's what
I'm trying to to flip is to create
enough margin and again again if I'm
going to be in front of a desk six or
eight hours a day that I need to be
doing strength training every day or you
know five six days a week um so that's
some of the things that I would change
there I also as we pivot into the
marriage side and relationship and
spouse side my Sonia is an amazing woman
and she we're we recently started
counseling again and it was kind of
funny and she just goes you know she's
telling Leticia she goes you know and it
admittedly is kind of hard being married
to Shawn because he is type A and really
driven and he has a lot of vision and
sometimes I'm feeling just like
overwhelmed with what's on our plate now
and he's talking about 3 months 6 months
12 years you know yeah a year 12 years
from now he's talking about this other
stuff and I'm like I'm just trying to
you know kind of survive what it is
today and so I think a lesson I could
learn is also just pacing myself having
more emotional awareness and empathy for
her and everybody around me on on the
rise
and today these days I preach patience
in terms of like slow and steady wins
YouTube's a marathon and not a Sprint I
think I could look back and have even
just a little bit more patience we're
about to approach my 40th birthday at
the time of recording this thick media
is seven years old we might do seven or
eight million Topline Revenue right now
we like 25 W2s we'll probably be 30 soon
add up all the contractors and vendors
and other people that are in the orbit
it's like 35 40 people these
days and honestly it's like we're
further than I ever could have imagined
and here becomes the question what if it
actually took though what if it wasn't
until it was 45 that we were where we
are right now these are like impossible
things to really measure because you do
you are fighting for survival and you're
fighting to like capture gaps in the
market in certain timings you want to
strike why the iron is hot we look at
what's happening in the crater economy
so it's it's a whole tension to be
managed but for the thought
exercise if let me just let's just say a
year if I stretched out an additional
year of leisure and breaks and rest 52
weeks and peppered 52 weeks I'm I'll be
married 20 years and two years to Sonia
over the last 18 years if I just would
have given more time 52 weeks is crazy
that's a couple more vacations a little
bit more rest for my own health for a
relationship to slow down the process I
would I would if I could change it I
would I would have gone a little bit
slower and maybe we aren't as far as we
are now so what would I go back and
change spouse- wise or people also talk
about working with your partner man it's
funny we've been married 18 years and I
think that this sounds cliche but it's
profound and that is communication and
relationships is
everything and so I feel like we're back
in kindergart garden now as we are we we
had this counselor from years ago we're
meeting with her again and like she's
telling us stuff like she's like so you
know like sea like you have to like
communicate with your wife and she's
also like Sonia like you need to like
communicate with Shawn and so it's like
we know we are we think we are
communicating but really speaking in
such a way that your spouse understands
they oftentimes say like men speak blue
women speak pink being patient to make
sure that things are understood carving
out time to communicate and then
communicating about details and what we
realize the pressure in the current
moment that I think is a big takeaway
for the podcast is that when you start
adding if you start aspiring for
more you need to also upgrade your
lifestyle and your tool set sets and
your habits and your routines to be able
to handle more so a lot of people
listening to this are aspiring for more
they may they want to start a side
hustle and earn extra money they want
they do have kids that they want to
raise well and one spouse is working and
they want to earn some extra money and
maybe a retired that spouse they've got
medical bills they've got these
different things and they're trying to
build an online business make money
online that's an aspiring for more
you're now going to take on pressure
that normal people wouldn't no no one's
right or wrong if somebody loves their
career and is happy and wants to get off
work and have Leisure and relax and
check out it at you know 5:00 p.m. get
home and cook and like and eat dinner
and celebrate you absolutely should do
that just know though that the path of
Entrepreneurship and building the side
hustle on your way there is like after
your day job then it's like get home
spend five minutes connecting start
chipping away at the side hustle still
put the kids down stay up even later do
whatever it takes that's increased
pressure and as increased pressure goes
up it's harder to communicate so what
Sony and I are now feeling is like we've
noticed even just the complexity of our
life it's an incredible blessing but it
brings hardship and this we try to live
in two
states uh we're so blessed that we have
nannies but it's like managing and Sonia
manages all these details and then it's
like we got the business we're hiring
new people and then we've got different
functions and things we're putting on
the calendar and we're to small town
kids college dropouts trying to figure
out how to run a company and every year
we've never been there before and we
never will we we don't know what it's
like to run the company this level of
sophistication and whatnot so we're
trying to also focus on learning faster
than we've ever been before hiring
coaches and mentors good thing we're in
counseling working on you know getting
back in and so all of that is that the
commun the need of communication is what
worked yesterday when the pace was 60
miles per hour now it's 100 miles per
hour or there's just more complexity
added in we need a greater set of tools
and we need that business versus
personal life versus the aspiration of
the YouTube channel versus what are you
going through versus how our our
personal relationships all these
different things so trying to summarize
in a valuable sense for The Listener is
like just know that you aspiring to
start a YouTube channel or you ASP
aspiring to build an online business is
going to induce more pressure open up
channels of communication process things
with your partner be patient if they
don't fully understand and see the same
vision that you see uh invest if
possible you know invest
in coaching and mentoring a lot of times
we don't hire a counselor until there's
a problem when ultimately not all
amateurs have coaches but all
professionals do and tiger when he's
playing golf he's got coaches when he's
winning so even even if you don't feel
like there's a need it's always helpful
to invest in in clear communication
Clear Vision truly getting Buy in from
the other person whatever it takes that
could be really helpful and there's been
seasons of pain that I've caused Sonia
or just seasons of frustration in our
marriage that could have been solved by
relationships counseling coaching me
slowing down a little bit and just
making sure our communication was tip
toop I it's invaluable to say from
looking back at a decade now in this
industry as an entrepreneur that one of
your main takeaways is have a little bit
more grace and time for yourself like
you said if it had taken you one more
year longer to get to where you are
today it would have been worth it so
that takeaway I think is um so
incredible because most people aren't
saying that there today that that would
would have been worth the investment in
your relationship and in your health um
all right Sean this one this is about
the critics and the trolls here what was
the most hurtful comment you've ever
received and how did it affect your
content or your approach to YouTube so
one of the funniest comments and we just
got a second one was somebody left a
comment and they said why does this man
have the face of a boy but the hair of
an old man
and someone just on a Instagram Q&A just
asked H how did your hair become so gray
when you're so
young so you know this is the kind of
encouragement that you get by opening up
the comment section on YouTube what's
funny was I was like I don't know you
know like how do how do I answer that I
was like maybe you think I look younger
cuz sometimes people go dang you look
kind of young and I'm like well I'm 40
and they're like oh you're 40 it's like
oh the grade revealed it so honestly
though those don't
I I find those
humorous you know sometimes the most
hurtful comments are the ones that have
some truth in
them um and I learned a quote from Billy
Graham that always stuck with me and
they said that he said if you can get to
a place where you actually benefit and
learn from your critics it's to your
advantage
because the
outrageous negative or weird or toxic
comments that have no basis in reality
those aren't the ones that get under our
skin it's the comments that maybe are
still unfair mean Super rude not
something anyone would ever say to
someone's face but have some level of
Truth in it and I know a lot of
listeners are maybe afraid if someone
calls out their teeth or calls out
something that's true about the way they
look or that points out sometime some
something in the way you communicated
and um yeah it's easy for me to take
those things personally I mean I'll take
things personally we just uploaded a
clip from the Seattle Studio where I
just switch while I'm going through
coffee with Cel and there was like
massive feedback about like these camera
uh C camera angle switches is horrible
this really breaks my attention one
person was like I can't even trust
somebody who switches their camera this
much or something you know so I don't
know so I think that that negative
comments and troll they affect me
probably a lot more than people realize
but it's been one of the skill sets also
that I've that just comes with the
territory that you have to grow so I've
intentionally tried to grow
understanding the principle that you got
to have thick skin but keep a soft
heart um to try to listen to feedback
especially if someone says this felt
inauthentic or I felt like you
misrepresented this or whatever I think
actually the person who closes their ear
too much to the audience's feedback
ultimately is going to lose on YouTube
and then of course you get into the
world of like just by the sheer nature
that we sell an online course or that we
could be in the internet marketing
associated with that world more than
Associated it just be like we obviously
Market on the internet um you know a lot
of times people call you a scam or
they'll call you this or that and I'm
I'm incredibly empathetic to those
things and it makes me think about being
thoughtful about just messaging and
communication you know I have learned
though I
heard I can't remember who it was but it
was actually like Warren Buffett it was
Charlie Munger who said if you don't
have 5 to 10% of people complaining that
your prices are too high or that you're
charging too much or
that
um that ultimately you're not charging
enough that you should be pushing your
product your service
and so there's a lot of mindset work to
understand to of course build your
product to actually be excellent in this
case we're talking about a product
that's not on course or write a book I
mean same thing like it's funny that
that somebody could complain about a
book that costs $4.99 on Kindle or 10
bucks on Amazon that took years to write
that's full of gold and wisdom and
somebody could say you know this is a
total ripoff and of course you can
return it you can return the Kindle
return the Amazon uh audible so it's
kind of being okay with that that like
there's going to be a percentage of
people and as Aristotle said the only
way to avoid
criticism is to say nothing is to do
nothing is to be
nothing and
so I count it a privilege and a a sign
that I'm doing something right when I
get negative comments trolls
Etc um and I try to keep a soft though I
don't want to just say it's the haters
and they don't know I want to keep a
vantage point of love for everybody
there empathy for everybody there and I
want to spot Trends I want to be
Discerning enough it's if I get I think
this is important in math so because
what we there's there's two equations my
friend John aov did haters math 99
positive comments plus one negative
comment equals one negative comment the
only thing that you think about is
the negative comment I'm thinking about
in the shower man what do do I really
look that old you know like was that or
am I a scam like what's you know you
start like cycling on that thought well
the reverse I guess it's kind of the
same equation but the reverse equation
is Is We I think media have created the
formula of like let's do the math I get
really emotional about a video is the
video succeeding or performing I'll read
one or two negative comments I'll be
like people hate it I think it's
important to take a step back and and
actually think about the like to dislike
ratio which isn't necessarily shown
public they they were hiding dislikes or
whatever but you can see the percentage
in your YouTube studio and in the
YouTube Studio we'll see something like
96% which is low for us is how many
people like the video a lot of times
it's 97 98 and a half so I didn't do
super great in high school really wasn't
for me I think I had an aptitude for
learning but I wanted to learn practical
World skill skills and Entrepreneurship
and not necess necessarily the
traditional education system so I want
to say I maybe averaged a 3.0 29 or 32
GPA and I remember on test you know if I
got a
86b you know if I got a B+ even an A
minus you know that was amazing
97% is such an insane approval rating
with most of those people hitting the
like button actually are enjoying the
content getting value and they're being
silent a lot of times the most vocal
people on the internet are the most hurt
toxic
cynical
critical and you got to ask the question
how is it that they even have time to
type and give that response busy
productive ambitious enterprising
individuals are building they're
watching learning and taking action and
they're not necessarily going to get
involved in that level that's not to say
that someone shouldn't leave a negative
comment and that's true about all people
but it is to say that I've got to look
at the math and I still get caught up in
my emotions cuz I'll get one negative
comment on the podcast and I'll spin off
even a title crew in slack or something
with you know Kyle and Steph and I'll be
like something's wrong with this video I
think we missed it are we like did we
say it wrong should we use this
different word in the title and it's
also nice I realize shows how irrational
I am I'll get like Nolan just being like
I think the the the title's fine why is
why are people offended and here's my
thing I read one
comment 500 likes positive
10 likes
negative 25 positive comments one
comment pointing something out if I was
more objective as I'm trying to be here
as we evaluate the emotions I get caught
up in it's not really a big deal like
that's all tracking mathematically as it
should be yet I think we sometimes can
overemphasize the negative comment so I
think there's something about doing the
math and the long road around the
mountain to pull the principal out is if
the video had a 60% like to dislike
Ratio or there's a crazy theme of A lot
of people and sometimes I've seen this a
couple episodes they've been like I love
your stuff I normally love what you're
doing I I would love think media podcast
love the team this episode fell off I
think we need to be open to that and I
think we're in a really dangerous
place if those types of feedback we
close our heart to now ego's getting a
little too big Pride's getting a little
too big that's a little bit more rare
and so I think it's look at the big data
the data is there to give you feedback
and we should be listening to that it's
going to make us better content creator
who do you compare yourself to I'd like
to say that I compare myself to my
yesterday's previous
best um which I do think is true I'm
guilty though of I think falling into
comparison in all
directions one thing that's interesting
is you know I could probably be really
insecure that I'm not a a absolutely
ripped gigantic alpha male muscle guy
which maybe is how people are wired or
whatever I'm pumped to get into shape
and and it's a longer road than I
thought but I think I'll be you know
Brad Pit Fight Club ripped which is also
the aspiration is a health aspiration
more than a physique you know vanity
aspiration but I'm not trying to say I'm
a saint that's cool too as a byproduct
so there's like certain maybe there's
certain categories what I'm getting at
is there's certain categor where like I
don't compare myself so I don't I'm not
like insecure
around athletes around bodybuilders
maybe because that's not my domain I
think where I get a little sensitive is
just people in my domain so it could be
other YouTuber peers in niches or
adjacent niches that are um their
Channel's growing faster they're getting
more views uh I think it's other
business owners I would say though
that what has helped me and as a
theme has
been
the I almost enjoy I do enjoy putting
myself in situations
where I'm the dumbest person in the room
and I'm the least successful in the room
this actually might have
been one of the keys to whatever success
I've accomplished
a lot of people get jealous
insecure they avoid people that are more
successful they talk behind their back
they tear them down
they perhaps look for the weaknesses or
flaws in those individuals and
articulate and talk about those and
highlight
those which is a losing
strategy there's just something that is
so awesome about getting around somebody
that's more successful and here's the
key and honoring that person having I
think the mentality in the
heart to respect greatness and then also
to take the student mentality to say
this is an opportunity to learn so
that's kind of how I've tried to be
positioned where I remember Alex and
Lila Heros dm' me and sent me a video um
laughing because on stage when they
spoke at our event I was like you know
we've been out here on think media
building this thing at the time for six
years and got to like about $6 million a
year um and then Alex fosi shows up on
the scene and does gym launch from like
Zer to 100 in 12 months and I'm like
what am I even doing why am I even
trying that kind of humor and that
joking is actually really my mentality
is also like self-depreciating not
actually putting down or being insecure
about whatever I've accomplished but
also recognizing like that's absolutely
insane it's a different degree of
greatness a different degree of Mastery
of course how we define success is so
multifaceted but game recognize game so
if someone's truly getting provable and
verifiable results in business the
biggest losing strategy that people can
have is to critique that I find it so
shocking it's also funny is people
really do they try to like maybe they'll
amplify someone's style I don't like
their style I don't like they look
they're too braggy on social media
they're too this I've learned the art of
eating the meat and throwing out the
bones if there's something to learn from
the person and by the way I it's like
why would you want to learn how to get
in shape from the overweight Fitness
coach why would you want to learn how to
build a successful business from someone
who's only done it in theory or not in
the actual real world or doesn't have
extraordinary results so I guess the
final thing I would say is Simon s kind
of coined this concept of having worthy
Rivals so there's this whole thing of
comparison is the thief of joy and it's
the killer of creativity and that's true
but I actually think that true greats
and real leaders
they find a place where if comparison is
leading you to insecurity you should
block and unfollow the person for a
season maybe but where you really have a
superpower is if comparison is
challenging you to be better
so positive comparison is having worthy
Rivals that when somebody shows up it
doesn't make you insecure or jealous
they show up and they're doing better
than you it challenges you to step up
your grain it identifies that maybe
you've gotten a little complacent maybe
you're a little too comfortable Maybe
you should so therefore I'm grateful
when maybe somebody brings something
innovate Innovative to YouTube they
start doing better and I don't think
about putting that person's success down
my question is how can I learn from them
how can I observe what they're doing how
can I see what they're doing and to
honor and respect them I've tried to
also articulate that on Twitter in
person at events going up to who would
be a competitor I should be jealous of I
try to flip it and go honor them and
articulate and say man I love what
you're doing I respect what you're doing
it's incredible you're bringing true
Innovation to the game and I love it I'm
learning from you I'm taking notes I'm
studying and um that is what's been
helpful to me it has challenged me to be
better and that perspective has served
me it's a really great healthy mindset
around comparison and jealousy but um I
I do want to name I want a name of
somebody that you are jealous of on
YouTube or maybe a business owner maybe
that counts I think that um people I've
been jealous of
one
is I'm getting smarter now as it
pertains to like the work you mentioned
earlier like the awareness of taking
more time off in the last 18 years so
our theme this year for think media is
built to last and and what I mean by the
work is obviously on Instagram I'm the
rise and grind guy people mistake it it
means rise and Brew your coffee I guess
it also means like grind but people
always critique grind they're like why
would you want to grind you know gears
grinding together that's like bad I'm
like dude relax oh it's toxic hustle
culture I'm like okay whatever dude like
grind your coffee beans and get to work
um but but uh I always have a a second
or two of jealousy when I talk to a
business owner who has optimized their
business in such a way that they've like
created total freedom and the reason
it's like attention is it's
self-awareness cuz I actually love what
I do love being here I love being with
you love making content there's times
when you know the margin can probably be
cranked up or a little bit of the rest
but I remember like I was uh on a ski
trip with Nick I'm actually forgetting
this gentleman's name it was Nick's Nick
from gra SK gella this guy was the uh
original I want to say he was the
founder of red giant which is a software
company that does plugins um all these
different cool 3D plugins and by the way
to the point of learning from worthy
Rivals this conversation and this trip
changed my life so this guy and I'm
sorry I forget his name and Nick are
skiing I'm snowboarding we're in
Colorado and um he's asking me about my
business now at the time too I was like
very much a solo this might have been
2016 not solo but like in pertaining to
content there was no like Nolan or Omar
making videos so I'm really the engine
of creating videos Maybe we had editing
help but I'm still probably editing a
lot and so I'm pushing 50 60 70 hour
weeks there's an analogy in personal
Brands
called the dancing bear and that
is you don't actually really have a real
business if you're the dancing bear and
if you stop dancing the money stops
coming in this a lot of trap that a lot
of content creators are in like if you
stop producing content it stops the
brand deal stops so this is where you
ask the question of can I build a real
business so I'm the dancing bear like I
got to be on camera and I got to keep
dancing and I got to keep editing videos
and then maybe we start we created an
online course but nevertheless got to
keep promoting it got to keep hustling
and those are the nature of operating a
business but I'm also we're having some
early success in think media so I'm kind
of getting accolades getting seen
getting viewed getting invited a few
places and I described all of that to
this gentleman founder of red giant on
the cheer lift and he looks at me and he
goes man that sounds awful he's like
that sounds like the worst and he's also
and I was like yeah I'm in videos and
I'm in a couple videos I'm doing social
media content he's like boy that sucks
bro like I'm really sorry to hear that I
was like what do you mean and he was
like I would hate like being on camera
and being public and like making content
all the time and he was like you know I
was like okay and then he was like you
know what's interesting is even though I
founded this company the current staff
and and everybody there they don't even
know who I am he's like there's actually
now a different CEO and he goes I spend
most of my time now like this last week
I was building shelves for my
six-year-old daughter's classroom in her
school I'm I'm out here skiing with you
guys like I don't got to do anywhere I
got to be anywhere I'm independently
wealthy and I have like no worries and
like red Giant's growing more without me
there than it was when I was there and I
was
my whole Paradigm was actually really
stretched kind of in that moment now
what's interesting is it's a
self-awareness thing because honestly if
I had nothing to do in relation to
operating think that isn't my core
desire I'm trying to find that balance
of I do want to be off work at 5 home
with the family I do want to architect
how many weeks off or vacations and
experiences but I but the this company
has been built around a passion and a
mission and purpose so I often times I
think it's even important to do the math
for The Listener like think about the
math for your life like do you want to
work 60 70 or 80 there's some people who
are driven by Madness not in a negative
way that they actually enjoy that I
think about one of my mentors Patrick B
David that's where he is I just talked
to him I was like so how many how many
hours a week are you putting in he I
said 80 he goes no question right no
question no like and and loves to do it
and somehow gets his family to church on
Sunday and other people from value
tainment and making memory with his kids
and I mean work is maybe fly he bought
like part of the New York Yankees so
like fly to New York bring your kids
meet with some business people whatever
well I don't want to work 80 but then
the flip side is like well are you
trying to work 10 nah I'd be super bored
I don't want to work 10 so so I think
it's kind of trying to figure it out so
anyways long answer to the jealousy
question is when someone is just so
smart that like the thing they've built
has produced a lot of wisdom you almost
can make that biblical where I think if
you're working too much it does affect
your attitude it happened to what Mary
and Martha Mary was like chilling with
Jesus and Martha was like pissed that
Mary was like just hanging out and
Martha was cleaning the house and like
cooking like Jesus don't you see all the
stuff that I'm doing like there a lot of
principles you could have from that
story but I think one of the stories is
that if if you're
unrested tired eyes rarely see a bright
fure future you start being short start
being more mean you start having a
shorter fuge a shorter temper and so
sometimes maybe after I've been hustling
I'll meet somebody that has insane
efficiency or lifestyle built into their
business and when I'm in a fatigued
State that's that's probably when the
emotion of jealousy arises the most you
know Tim Ferris 4-Hour Work week which
is kind of a marketing title but
nevertheless he built that business to
be super efficient I'll be like with 4
hours work week you know that's insane
and if that's offending you you probably
need a nap you probably need a break and
uh that's probably true about me all
right without naming names have you ever
had a collaboration that has gone wrong
uh
yeah uh I mean there's people that we've
collaborated with that are in jail right
now so that went wrong um you know and
if I we didn't obviously know the
different situations that's an extreme
one
I think
luck the lesson here's a big lesson the
lesson of 2022 for me the lesson of 2022
for me was to slow down and be very
thoughtful about who we partner or
collaborate with so without really
naming names that
situation was somebody in a company that
we partnered with in relation to our
event growth video live the here's the
big
mistake one I had built trust with this
person because they had attended our
church for a couple years lesson is just
because someone's at church or whatever
doesn't mean that they are trustworthy
or that they can't be duplicitous you
know one of my favorite books right now
is trust by Dr Henry cloud and it talks
about track record being one of the
attributes of trust but here's the
problem Bernie maid off had a good track
record record he built that Ponzi scheme
I want to say for over a decade so
what's so wild about that is Word of
Mouth friend of a friend could endorse a
person who has had a track record of 5
10 years even and that person could
still turn out to be evil so some of
that could be stuff that's happening in
life but here was my mistake I did not
involve you I did not involveed Sonia in
even the Genesis meeting with this
person and it was like it kind of went
got a little weird it was just going to
be kind of a sort of collab kind of a
sponsor of the event I wouldn't it
wasn't a partnership collab is a better
word nevertheless that was a massive
lesson and a failure and mistake of mine
to realize that if we're going to enter
into a
relationship a collaboration a
partnership and defining maybe the
different degrees of that that it was
Hasty for me or just a blind spot of
mine to
not
involve trusted individuals with
different perspectives on the team and
then there was another social media
influencer who was under
investigation who perhaps had the FTC
looking into them and had a lot of stuff
happening and I talked
with um my friend Caleb Ron who works
for Gary vaynerchuk and works for um
Alex Heros now
and this conversation reinforced the
theme of the year there's about two
other scenarios but this also reinforced
and he said we're being very thoughtful
about who we co-sign it's one of the
things he learned from Gary Vee one of
the things Alex and Lila being very
thoughtful with who we co-sign who we
partner with and then we started talking
about degrees because we'll maybe have
people on be like it's one thing if
you're interviewed on somebody else's
show it's a chance to influence it's one
thing if they're interviewed on your
show
one thing if they're vendors if they're
Partners if they're sponsors really good
topic to bring up and a huge lesson that
I've learned so enough happened in 2022
that I I see sometimes God speaks to me
I really sense this or I've tracked in
in my history it even talk talks about
in the Old Testament that God speaks in
dreams Visions he speaks through his
word he speaks to different in different
ways to different people this sounds
weird but but God really does speak to
me in threes like sometimes all see I'll
be reading in the Bible I will read a
book later and that exact principle will
be established there and then on the
news there'll be a news story about like
a CEO that went through and I'll be like
dude that was insane and it'll all be in
the same day and I'll be like whoa you
know God you really speak in M
mysterious ways and you are speaking and
I'll see those types of things well
again these are just general wisdom
lessons the cynic would be like well you
should just learn from your mistakes and
I'll be like yeah but this was like a
year where like God was like hey uh be
careful who you partner with and do your
due diligence my wife Sonia has really
got a gift of discernment so do you and
the team directors and other people have
different Vantage points and really
collectively together here's the thing
we could all still be tricked by a
Bernie maid off but we're going to
increase our L our longevity and our
chances of not making a major mistake by
slowing down doing our research getting
a second opinion or even just yeah not
rushing into something uh you know by
myself and just getting other
stakeholders and decision makers
involved so um I will say this we look
at Sony and I interpret history
different which is our right to do so
like we look back she looks back and
she's like you know if you would have
listened to me and she's right if if you
would have listened to me you know we
could have avoided this and for me I
always say I'm like well once the train
left the station I mean we had this
partnership was going people are already
involved and people are already
and all this information didn't come out
till I want to say a month or two after
the event in in The Grow video live
situation but nevertheless I go well
you're right of course like if we could
if we could change it we should have but
to me it was a lesson that we could
learn from I don't know if it's it's
that I would regret it was that I feel
like we're given an opportunity with how
we're building the company and our theme
this year is built to
last is this whole idea of be careful
how you build your God Grace has
protected Us in certain situations in
the past and in the future there's also
times where like we need wisdom and we
need discernment and we need haste makes
mistakes we want to walk calculated we
want to be careful and so that's
definitely something that I've wanted to
apply moving forward that I really
learned in 2022 our community will often
send us emails of like the people
hitting them up in the DMs like hey buy
my product and then I'll sponsor you or
these different um what I would say are
scam
yeah so have you ever gotten got
especially the beginning of your journey
I have never sent money to a Nigerian
prince uh I've been tempted to because I
was offered there was a million dollars
of an unclaimed inheritance for like a
Nigerian King and he was he needed
somebody to give the money to and so his
representative emailed me and all he
needed was my bank account number Social
Security number and pin number what an
opportunity I know and he was going to
transfer the money I got close um I
think my history as the Director of
communications at a
church
um as a digital immigrant being on the
internet and social media has been
helpful in the sense
of spotting scams so I've never sent
money to a Nigerian prince I've gotten
emails that have been you know fishing
malware I really don't think I you know
I click on them too much I actually do
have some stories I got called by the
IRS that's a good one you know this is
the IRS and I was like oh my gosh and
then I was like oh it's a scam and so as
scammers are getting more sophisticated
and my heart goes out to people because
especially people that are maybe a
little bit older a little bit more naive
I mean crypto scams all over the
Instagram comments YouTube comments um
just this whole idea of like send me
money on the internet no I've never
fallen into that and with the brand deal
stuff I I've gone pretty far down the
road like oh my gosh they think I'm so
like cool and fashionable that they want
to send me sunglasses you know and
sponsor me I just have to like pay for
them it's not talking about it's really
just like maybe it's not a scam it's
just sales they're like I mean it is but
it's like yeah the way to get you know
influencers to buy your sunglasses is to
just sell it to them in the DMS making
them think they're being sponsored by
paying for it but but there's a couple
things that happened to me one I
installled I installed team
viewer of some kind of app like that on
my computer and that got hacked which
allowed the person who logged in it was
so that Microsoft could like fix
something by taking over my desktop well
a hacker hacked it took over my desktop
and went to like eBay and some places
where my credit card information was
saved and mailed themselves about $1600
worth of gift cards from various
websites that they could just that were
already logged into and I remember I
woke up in the morning curious about
what was happening on my desktop and
realized and then I went to the history
and realized that all this activity was
happening between 1:00 a.m. and 5:00
a.m. and I'm like I figured Sonia
probably wasn't up on my computer and so
luckily fraud and credit cards uh you
know fraud protection refunded all the
money and shut all that down of course
there was the time when the think media
podcast Channel got hacked that was very
significant and that was Pro probably
browser hijacking cookie hijacking
that's the whole nature of your YouTube
channel being managed by multiple people
and I would recommend listeners check
out a link in the show notes or watch
that episode I think there's one or two
episodes we had a special guest who's an
expert in protecting yourself so I think
there's um there's that one I've
invested in some business experiments
that have lost
$7,000 uh here and there and I think I
the big key there was I was going into
it knowing I could lose the money I
think that's important and it was a
calculated risk but generally I'm I'm
pretty Greatful that I've
avoided being full-on scammed for the
most part definitely putting yourself
out there on the internet might like
creates a target for people to do that
but you are mentioned having the
self-awareness to sometimes know like
yeah I'm not really a fashion influencer
so that's probably not like a legit
brand deal someone's offering me right
now yes if you liked this episode then
make sure you like comment subscribe
share this episode with other people who
could find it valuable and just as a
reminder we have our think media sale
going on right now you can find it at
think Medias sale.com um it's our viral
video bundle incredible selection of
courses we'll have that all linked up
for you in the show notes and we'll see
you on the next one